[Applause]
[Music]
normally on new releases we take a look
at some of the biggest games launching
in a particular week but since it's a
brand new month we figured it's a good
time to look at all of September it is
the start of the busy season after all
so while this episode highlights games
over a wider span remember that you can
always subscribe to get new releases
every Sunday with a closer look at that
specific week let's get started
September kicks off with a sequel that
no one really asked for but knack to who
seems to be changing things up for the
better for starters all that platforming
sighs changing beat-em-up action can be
experienced with a friend who will take
control of a blue-colored neck you can
also be upgraded through the new skill
tree when you collect relic energy in
each of the levels you and your co-op
buddy can jump in exclusively on ps4 on
Tuesday September 5th and now for a
sequel that everyone asked for destiny 2
features all the trademark cooperative
and competitive shooting but now with
tons more guns and class options hunters
have a new Ark Strider subclass that
wields a mighty spear the warlocks dawn
blade can rain down solar energy from
above and the Titans Sentinel option
flies around with a magic shield of
course there are also new raids and side
quests to take on plus a more robust
social space called the farm destiny 2
launches for ps4 and Xbox one next week
on Wednesday September 6 but if you're
craving some space shooting action right
now you can check out any of our
gameplay clips from the farm the opening
mission or the open beta maybe you
prefer to take your spacefaring games on
the go
in that case check out Metroid Samus
returns this reimagining of 1991's
Metroid 2 brings some great new tweaks
to samus his adventure for starters she
has a melee attack for dealing critical
damage to enemies and she can freely aim
in any direction
classic power-ups like the super
missiles and grapple beam are back
alongside new upgrades like the scan
pulse which can help you locate secret
items in passages
samus returns on 3ds on Friday the 15th
and I guess there's still more space
stuff to talk about
because Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite is
all about the galactic Infinity stones
Marvel's Ultron teams up with megaman
x's sigma to merge the universes and
conquer everything but you'll have a big
roster of fighters ready to stop them
including newcomers like Black Panther
Captain Marvel and Jetta the Infinity
stones themselves have a place in combat
to the mind stone for example performs a
full stun command grab you can throw
down on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Tuesday
the 19th just don't get too upset when
you inevitably meet your match online
now let's come back down to earth with
the most popular sport in the world
FIFA 18 has two big things in common
with last year's release it runs on EA's
frostbite engine and it continues Alex
hunters story in the journey mode
Ultimate Team legends are also back in
the ps4 Xbox one and PC version of the
game though they're now called Ultimate
Team icons in any case you'll still have
tons of stadiums and teams to play
around with FIFA 18 comes to ps4 ps3
Xbox one Xbox 360 PC and Nintendo switch
on Friday the 29th and those are some of
the hottest games we'll be playing all
month long as always remember that
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with a regular episode of new
releases next week